let's consider a very famous problem the
Atwood machine we have a pulley a
suspended from the ceiling and a rope is
wrapped around the pulley and on each
side of the Rope there is different
masses so here's a block one and block
two and we can say here it doesn't
matter but we'll say that M two is
bigger than N one and that gives us some
intuition that we expect block two to go
down and block one to go up now in this
problem there is friction between the
rope and the pulley so the Rope is not
sliding and what that means is that the
pulley will rotate and also the mass of
the pulley is not zero so these were all
assumptions we made way back when we
were analyzing Newton's second law but
now we have to take into a fact that
there's some rotational inertia to make
the pulley start to have angular
acceleration so what we'd like to do is
to identify our three objects mass one
the Pulliam mass two and for mass one
and mass to use Newton's second law for
the pulley will use our torque
relationships so let's begin by drawing
our Freebody diagrams for object 1 so we
have tension in the rope pulling object
1 up we have the gravitational force
down and here it doesn't matter which
way I'm going to choose my unit vectors
because I have this idea that m2 is
bigger than n1 I'm just going to choose
J hat 1 up now for block 2 I have m 2g
now here's the place where lots of
people get tripped up in the past we've
been assuming that the tension in the
rope is uniform everywhere in this
problem because the Rope is not slipping
and the pulley is not massless the
tension is not constant everywhere in
the rope and we'll see more reasons why
that can't be the case so I'll have to
identify a different tension on the
other side t2 pulling the rope pulling
the block
up and I'm gonna choose J hat to down
notice my unit vectors are chosen in
opposite directions the reason for that
is that there's a constraint here that
as block two goes down block one goes up
if the acceleration of block 2 is
positive the acceleration of block 1
will also be positive if I choose unit
vector pointing up so now I can write
Newton's second law for both of these so
for block 2 positive down m2 G minus t2
equals m2 a it's the same acceleration
in the Rope a is equal to a 1 equal to a
2 they're all positive and for to notice
that have positive up minus m1 G equals
m1 a so so far these are my two
equations I have three unknowns T 1 T 2
and the accelerations and only two
equations now let's analyze the pulley
so we have our pulley a and what are the
forces on the pulley
well forces and torques are a little bit
different but let's just draw our forces
first there is a tension holding it up
we'll call that T 3 from this rope
pulling it up now here's where we have
to be careful rope one is pulling the
pulley down that's what we called T 1 so
we draw a T 1 on this side and the same
rope on the other side is pulling the
pulley down notice that it is a
different T 2 now this brings us to what
we called our rotational coordinate
system I do know expect that the angular
acceleration of the pulley so as the
pulley rotates in this problem I expect
that it's rotating in the direction like
my right hand rule this way and so I
expect to see the Alpha pointing like
that with that in it what I'll do is
I'll choose
a coordinate system for an angle-theta
and that will make positive direction
like that for my rotational coordinate
system now when we write torque equals
the moment of inertia of the pulley
times the angular acceleration we have
two torques the radius is our radiuses
of R and if we draw if we're calculating
the torque about the center of the
pulley we'll call that point O then each
of these torques are in different
directions so for instance we would have
to take 41 going down and this vector
from the origin to where T 1 is acting
we can extend that force and we see that
that torque is pointing in the direction
direction like that and that's opposite
or a sign here so this torque minus T
one R is negative what about the torque
from the other force T to again we would
draw that vector let's draw them over
here we have T two pointing down the
point O is there the vector from o to
two is pointing like that we extend that
vector we put the arrow like that and we
see that this one is pointing in our
positive direction so we have a plus T
to our equals
I alpha now right away we can see why
the tension in the strings is not the
same because if these tensions were the
same this quantity would be zero but the
tensions can't be the same because the
pulley is rotating and that rotational
inertia of the pulley is coming from the
fact that the two torques are not the
same on both sides so we now have our
last equation here T to R minus T 1 R
equals I a alpha but notice that I've
introduced another variable here so I
again I have four equations and only
three unknowns we still have one last
constraint because the rope is sliding
along the pulley and the radiuses are we
know that a point on the rim of the
pulley has acceleration a of the rope
but the pulley has an alpha angular
acceleration so our constraint condition
here is plus R alpha now why did I put a
plus sign because when the pulley is
rotating in the direction shown alpha
will be positive this quantity torque
will be bigger than this one and so
we'll have a positive alpha when I chose
J hat 1 up and J hat to down that made
all of my accelerations positive and so
I end with a plus sign if I had reversed
my choice of unit vectors then this
would be a minus sign so you have to be
extremely
careful by making sure that the
directions you chose for the linear
force diagrams that give us a and the
direction we chose in our rotational
coordinate system are consistent when we
choose to relate the constraints between
them so that's our last condition that a
equals R alpha so when I now have four
equations and four unknowns and if I
want to solve for the acceleration a
then I have to need a strategy here and
what I'll do to find a is I'll use this
equation that is my backbone why did I
do that because I have the unknowns T 2
T 1 and alpha and I have separate
equations that relate alpha 2 a and T 1
2 a and T 2 de and so I can solve for T
2 and substitute it in here I'll need a
little room so I get that T 2 is m2 G
plus m2 a sorry minus m2 a times R now T
1 is M 1 a plus M 1 G times art and
that's equal to I a times alpha which is
a over R so I'll now collect all of my a
terms over here and so I get M 2 G R
plus minus m1 G R this term and this
term is equal to a times I a over R
notice I have two plus signs here so I
get M 1 plus M 2 times R and I therefore
conclude we'll put it over here that the
acceleration a is equal to
m2 minus m1 G R / I a over R plus M 1
plus M 2 R now when I have this result
let's just check a number of things
first notice that if M 2 is bigger than
M 1 a will be positive which is what I
expected
dimensionally we have M 2 gr down here M
2 R so this first term will have
dimensions of acceleration G now over
here we have I a over R but remember
moment of inertia is M times R squared
so this also have the dimensions of mass
and radius and so I have confidence
dimensionally and the sign of a that
this is the correct answer and that's
how we solve the Atwood machine